跟高考比填志愿才是最能体现家庭认知差距的
尤其现在AI来的又快又猛
选择更是大于努力
20天讲透志愿填报的一切
今天空空一条视频
讲透AI时代普通家庭究竟该选啥专业
覆盖所有分数段
先说哪些不建议选
26年奥斯topic发布了人类技能AI替代率报告
这张AI失业雷达图里面蓝色覆盖的要慎选
红色覆盖的更要慎之又慎
不过大家先别慌
AI再厉害
这两种岗位短时间还替代不了
是有国家背书的
央国企
电网石油军工这类系统
你进去了饭碗是国家给的
不是市场给的
AI再猛也不好动力
第二种呢是未来的风口行业
比如人工智能
机器人
芯片等等
都是以后的刚需赛道
有国家政策兜底
有前沿技术支撑
不担心没饭吃
所以啊咱普通家庭的同学
要想在AI时代稳就业
选专业的思路就很清晰了
要么进体制
要么踩封口
接下来空空挨个给你盘一盘
这两个方向都推荐哪些专业出来能干啥
前景和待遇咋样
先来看好进央国企的专业奖金
电网推荐电气工程及其自动化
智能电网
信息工程
电气工程与智能控制
这类电工类专业
他们是进入国家电网南方电网的通行证
电网待遇是实打实的好
六险两金福利拉满
毕业生大多能进省市供电局电力设计院
二三线城市年薪10万上
下一线省会城市15万起步
进石油就选石油工程
油气储运工程
海洋油气工程这类石油类专业对接中石油
中石化
中海油
三大央企
很多人觉得石油是夕阳产业
大错特错
化工能源新材料哪样离得开石油
尤其是在23线城市的油田炼厂
管道公司绝对是当地的上等水平
很多岗位包吃包住
奖金高
几年下来能攒出一套房的首付
能吃苦
不介意去基层的同学
可以重点考虑进军工系统
推荐飞行器设计与工程
飞行器制造工程这类航空航天类专业
信息对抗技术
探测制导与控制技术
这类兵器类专业
以及船舶与海洋工程
核工程与核技术
中航工业
中船集团
中国兵工
中国电科这类老牌军工央企
每年定点去原航空航天部兵器部的院校招人
而且军工系统的技术积累非常深
你干10年
你就是行业专家
越老越值钱
如果想进铁路系统
建议选交通运输铁道方向
轨道交通信号与控制
交通设备与控制工程
车辆工程
铁道机车方向
本科进去转正后
年薪普遍在10万到15万
五险一金定格
交公积金能覆盖房贷
稳得发紫
只要不出大错
能干的退休
只不过很多岗位呢要倒班
风吹日晒是常态
确实比较辛苦
下面来看银行这些金融机构
金融学
经济学
会计学
财务管理
审计学这类经营管类的专业都能进
这些是六大行和地方农商行主要招录的专业
省市分行年薪12到15万
县域网点7万到11万
很多人担心财会被AI多章取代
但银行风控核查线下信贷尽调
企业实地审查离不开人工审核
核心业务岗比较稳定
不过加班是常态化
开门红
季末冲业绩的时候
连轴转营销压力大
不是大家想象中的朝九晚五
如果想去三大通信运营商
就紧盯着通信工程和信息工程
本科转正以后年薪八到12万
一线城市更高
二三线城市也是当地中上水平
六险两金
话费补贴
食堂住宿要啥有啥
通信行业技术更新快
你得一直学不学就跟不上
但跳槽也容易
运营商干几年
跳华为中心的大有人在
但空空提醒大家啊
进央国企最好要选对应行业的原部属院校
各省份的地头蛇
或者跟这些企业有合作的学校
不然机会少不说还卷的要死
然后是站在风口的专业AI机器人芯片
新能源
先进制造
医疗健康
这六大行业都是未来最热的赛道
咱们一个个来看
首先是AI啊
为啥站在风口
不用我多说
它是少有的
能提升所有行业生产效率的通用技术
未来10年都会有高速增长
缺人缺的发慌
学AI优先考虑人工智能
智能科学与技术
其次是计算机科学与技术
软件工程
自动化
统计学
应用统计学
数据科学与大数据技术
但框框说实话啊
只建议高分段能通98521的人选
AI这个行业两极分化非常严重
清北华五
两电一邮这学校出来的AI硕士起薪四五十万
大厂抢着要
但普通二本的人工智能专业师资不行
设备不行
就业对口率极低
很多毕业生最后还是去写了基础代码
甚至转行
然后是机器人
AI革命的背景之下
机器人是大势所趋
他能24小时无休干活
到2030年
巨生智能市场规模可以冲到4000亿
根本不怕被替代
专业呢推荐机器人
工程巨深智能未来机器人
海洋机器人
农业机器人自动化
坏消息是他也看学校吃资源
建议高分段的同学选
好消息是他不像AI那么硬
刚学历拼论文
很多公司更看重实际动手能力
动手能力强的
本科可以直接就业
应届本科年薪12到20万
硕士20到35万
当然如果学历一般
其实也能入行
可以做制造和售后
养活自己绝对没有问题
再来看芯片
作为所有电子设备心脏
AI算力的核心
是国家卡脖子的关键赛道
现在国产替代式刚需市场需求只会越来越大
专业方面
微电子科学工程
集成电路设计与集成系统
集成电路科学工程
电子科学与技术
电子封装技术
电子信息工程
这几个都不错
学出来后工资高
还稳得很
刚毕业的硕士一年能够拿到25到40万
基本没有中年危机
但和AI一样
对院校挑剔的很分儿不够
国家示范性微定学院28所这种强效的
如果你还想做设计
那最好别碰
学历一般的基本是入行做公益和封装
待遇呢也还不错
还有新能源
就是未来的能源命根子
有国策托底
10年内都是国家亲儿子想入这行
能源与动力工程
新能源科学工程
储能科学工程
材料科学工程
新能源材料与器件是首选
它不像前几个那么卷学历啊
双非只要专业对口
也能进光伏风电央企
国家电网储能部门
新能源车企和氢能装备厂
应届本科起薪10万到15万
硕士15到25万
就是不少岗位呢在工厂
在风电厂要倒班
环境苦了点
而且现在部分新能源像光伏有点产能过剩了
不算优选
至于先进制造
简单说就是用信息化和智能化的方式
提高工业生产的效率和质量
这是一个国家工业实力和全球竞争力的根本
所以也是好赛道
在15规划里面
已经上升到了极高的战略地位了
专业呢就选机械工厂
机械设计制造及其自动化
机械电子工程
智能制造
工程测控技术仪器
智能感知
工程等等
就业面非常广
任何有工厂的地方都需要你
车企工程机械
军工装备精密及企业一直都在招人
你要是分高就可以主攻智能制造
智能感知这种前沿方向
硕士普遍年薪能够在20万以上
中等的分数就选传统机械机电专业
综合年薪10万到14万
难度不大
最后是医疗健康
这个赛道没有周期
永远都热
第一啊
人都会生病
这是刚需
第二呢
疾病的种类又多又杂
而且人人都想长寿
那高端医疗设备
创新药和生物技术就会持续发展
建议选临床医学
口腔医学和生物医学工程
临床医学和口腔医学偏向一线诊疗
前期投入大
周期长
这个过程真的非常熬人
可一旦出头就稳了
一线城市
三甲医院医护人员综合年薪15到30万
二三线城市也能稳定在10万以上
如果不想做医生的生物医学工程
这类医工交叉专业
偏向医疗器械研发
医疗设备运维能进医疗企业和医院设备科
工作压力相对更小
就业也灵活
在变化越来越快的AI时代
咱普通家庭的孩子没有太高的试错成本
选专业很容易踩坑
但如果能认准体制和风口这两条路
踏踏实实往前走
就不怕AA的冲击
OK如果这期视频对你有帮助
别忘了点赞收藏加关注哦
我是空框
下期视频再见